le lancement aujourd'hui de l'opération
musée gratuit le premier dimanche du
mois une initiative de catherine
trautmann la ministre de la culture qui
a donné le coup d'envoi de cette formule
qui concerne les 34 musées nationaux
le public était au rendez-vous affluence
record pierre emmanuel luneau jean louis
normandin
aujourd'hui ces phrases si agréable à
l'oreille on pourra l'entendre désormais
tous les premiers dimanches du mois à
l'entrée de chacun des 34 musées
nationaux
aujourd'hui c'était la première mais
l'on sait déjà qu'il faudra être pas si
on pourra en profiter très fraîchement
musée cette initiative est l'une des
quatre mesures prises par catherine
trautmann pour faciliter l'accès à la
culture
outre les musées la mesure est étendue
aux monuments nationaux gratuits
également pour les moins de 18 ans toute
l'année cette fois enfin pour les cinq
théâtres nationaux tous les jeudis la
place sera 50 francs la gratuité c'est
gagner un nouveau public et c'est aussi
fidéliser peut-être un public qui
reviendra ensuite
donc je pense pas effectivement qu'il
faut une opération à perte c'est en tout
cas certainement quelque chose
d'important pour nous dans la mesure où
nous pouvons effectivement gagné à
public sinon ne seraient pas venus il
faut dire que la fréquentation des
musées en france se porte bien depuis sa
réouverture hier le centre pompidou a
déjà accueilli 80 mille visiteurs au
louvre
l'expérience de la gratuité du premier
dimanche du mois était menée depuis deux
ans résultat 70 % de fréquentation
supplémentaire pour le louvre
44% des personnes interrogées disent que
elles ne seraient pas venus visiter le
louvre s'il n'y avait pas eu cette
gratuité
donc nous pensons pouvoir gagner un
nouveau public quel que soit son âge
quelles que soient les générations à
partir de cette mission
le public jeune et peu fortunés donc
favorisés mais les habitués des lieux
eux sont plus dubitatifs
dans certains cas j'éviterai même parce
que je pense que ça va amener beaucoup
de foule et
on voit mal les expositions dans ces
cas-là une initiative populaire certes
encore faut-il qu'elle ne soit pas
victime de son succès